she's back it took two and a half years
but now Elena's new album is out it's
called crystal sky and she says the name
is perfect bahattin on Steam you
believed we were bouncing around ideas
and started thinking about what it would
be like if everything got snowed under
and we could all just start over again
that's why we came up with the metaphor
crystal design himmat and right away I
said yes then this is that's it skygo
fine when unhappy safada Kanaka does is
this and here she is shooting the video
to the single traffic lights this fourth
album was recorded in LA London and
Berlin without from a team of
songwriters and producers
my name was a collision see levan off
ian for my goal was to put what I feel
into music Vasek Suzanne fuller and
that's hard when it's not used sitting
in front of the computer creating the
sound mad insane sh-boom can so I wanted
to find the right people to help me
create what was already in my head in my
option Alice fetishes in 2010 Lena won
the eurovision song contest in Oslo with
the song satellite she just turned 19
and was completely unknown her hit song
topped the charts across Europe
the next year she competed again this
time in Dusseldorf with the song taken
by a stranger but she only made its
number 10 out of 25
strange back then she was a girl wonder
but these days the paparazzi have dialed
it back so few view by yes to tighten
the suppress isn't following me around
as much as right after I won the
Eurovision that was nice I had ten
strings attached to me and went wherever
they pulled me that was good at the time
I'm grateful to everyone who helped me
as well to tangle tundish Panzer tank
badasses in 2012 Lena came into her own
with her third album Stardust it went
platinum and she got an echo award for
the video
her first Torin big venues was a flop in
2013 she decided in favor of smaller
venues she's learned to take charge and
now that she's in the driver's seat
successes all the sweeter point is I've
also two masters these days I do it and
I enjoy it yet adverse andromax is fine
I know what the payoff is the max man
i'm making it happen he's been to tie
off get it it's fun exciting and I feel
like it's all really cool and I'm into
it at night I don't fall into bed like
wow I'm a wreck yes instead I think
today was great and I accomplished a lot
if they figure shaft on the outside I've
been waiting for an hour but it's
feeling like forever there are 14 songs
on her new album and Lena has one big
wish for them does the still light and a
fade fast man Matt but don't make people
happy with my music I do it for myself
to be offered mainly it's to make people
happy I hope I can keep doing that does
this test my fight on my hand off
this is the last album with her current
label there's no definite plan after
that but one thing's for sure Lena will
keep making music
you